we're starting today with something
that's sort of really funny but also sad
and really just a sign of how
disconnected from facts and rationality
we have gotten as a matter of sort of
standard political discourse in the
United States and I'll explain yesterday
there were impeachment hearings they
were the first hearings in the Judiciary
Committee everything in the weeks prior
was in the House Intelligence Committee
led by Adam Schiff yesterday nearly nine
hours of hearings we were there for
every minute live-streaming
nine hours of hearings overseen in the
Judiciary Committee by congressman Jerry
Nadler and they brought in Democrats
brought in three well-known legal
scholars to lay out the case for why
Donald Trump's actions meet the standard
required for impeachment now this is not
anything about would articles be filed
how would the trial go how would
senators vote it's merely legal experts
saying here's the standard for
impeachment here is historical
information here is legal information
and here is how Trump's actions fit into
that they were professors Noah Feldman
Pamela Carlin and Michael Gerard who did
this it was again nearly nine hours of
hearings the Republican strategy was
mostly talk only to their witness they
brought one witness Republicans did
Jonathan Turley and focused merely on
how he believes there is no need to
impeach there is no case for impeachment
but when Republicans did talk to the
three witnesses called by the Democratic
majority in the House of Representatives
the strategy was attack them attack
their credibility attack them personally
as biased partisan actors rather than
the legal experts that they are and one
of the funniest such attacks was from a
congressman named Matt gates now if you
don't know Matt gates you're probably
much happier in your life than people
who do know who this guy is because he
is such bottom-feeding you know anyway
he is one of the basest bomb throwers of
the we always defend Trump movement or
camp he tries to go after professor
carlin by pointing out that she made
legal political contributions and he
really sounds very dumb doing it take a
look at this I appreciate your testimony
professor Carlin you gave 2,000 bucks or
you gave a thousand bucks to Elizabeth
Warren right I believe so
you gave 1200 bucks to Barack Obama I
have no reason to question that and you
gave 2,000 bucks to Hillary Clinton
that's correct
why so much more for Hillary than the
other two because I've been giving a lot
of money to charity recently because of
all of the poor people in the United
States well those aren't the only those
aren't the only folks you've been given
to there's lots of poor people in the US
I found a professor Carlin quick-witted
and impressive and formidable as we
often hear floated around Gates
continued with this brutal prosecution
of Pamela Carlin take a listen now
youyou have you ever been on a podcast
called versus Trump I think I was on a
live panel that the people who Ram the
podcast called versus Trump on that do
you remember saying the following
liberals tend to cluster more
conservatives especially very
conservative people tend to spread out
more perhaps because they don't even
want to be around themselves did you say
that yes I did do you understand how
that reflects contempt on people who are
conservative know what I was talking
about there was the natural tendency if
you put the quote in context the natural
tendency of a compactness requirement to
favor a party whose voters are more
spread out well and I do again I'm very
I'm very limited on time professor and
so I just have to say when you talk
about how liberals want to be around
each other in cluster and conservatives
don't want to be around each other and
so they have to spread out it makes
people you may not see this from you
know like the ivory towers of your law
school but it makes actual people in
this country when you like this you
smell get to interrupt me on this time
now let me also suggest that when you
invoke the president's son's name here
when you try to make a little joke out
of referencing Barron Trump
does not lend credibility to your
argument it makes you look mean so
understand this is all they have if they
had more they would use it she was on a
podcast in talking about how the
districting requirements helped
Republicans they are biased towards
conservative these these are the
requirements that got us the
gerrymandering that we now have that so
favors Republicans while she was talking
about that on a podcast she throws in
sort of a joke but it's it's not even
really a joke because it actually does
go to why there is a structural
advantage for Republicans in districting
conservatives don't even want to be near
each other it is true that conservatives
have more rural tendencies in other
words there is a systemic structural
bias where the party the movement that
is more interested in living rural II
rather than living in an urban or more
more condensed fashion compact fashion
that is going to help Republicans have
more districts even with lower
population density anyway understand
that this is an attempted attack on her
credibility but it does nothing to
assail her legal knowledge which she was
there to provide and did in an extremely
accurate and precise way then gates
brings up Trump's son this was so
overblown Carlin said during the
hearings in talking about how Trump
can't be allowed to just control
everything it can't be just everything
as the way Trump wants she said Trump
doesn't get to make Baron a baron
meaning she doesn't get to make his son
Baron Trump a monarch right a baron is
sort of I think entry level of monarch
of some kind and Republicans went crazy
pretending that it was an attack on a
kid it's a complete and total joke
because that's all that they had here's
one other moment where another
Republican tried to get them to reveal
by a show of hands how they voted in
2016 which is of course something they
don't have to answer he's allowed to ask
they don't have to answer this is
Republican Tom McClintock trying that as
a strategy to attack the character of
the witnesses
Thank You mr. chairman could I begin
just with a show of hands how many on
the panel actually voted for Donald
Trump in 2016 I don't feel obligated to
say anything about how we can start
balance just show of hands I will not I
think you've made your positions
professor Carlin very general suspending
will suspend the clock to is to me you
may let me refresh and how many of you
thought to snap at the moment the
general may ask the question the
witnesses don't have to respond how many
Trump in 2016 show of hands not to keep
not raising our hands is not an
estimation of an answer sir this is all
they had tell us how you voted did you
once make a joke on a podcast years ago
still I maintain nothing may come of
this but the lines of questioning from
Republicans made it so clear that they
know they have nothing because this is
what they had to resort to unfortunately
also that probably played really well I
didn't watch any of the Fox News stuff
yesterday but it wouldn't be surprising
to me if they had video of Matt Gaetz
talking about a podcast that Professor
Carlin appeared on and framing it as wow
wow what a brutal indictment it wouldn't
shock me but big picture we know that
this type of stuff works even though it
is completely not based in assessing the
most important thing here which is the
legal case for the impeach ability of
Donald Trump